Eric says,
apologies to the weird question.
Have you ever performed a ritual sacrifice?
No,
I haven't.
And it is a weird question,
although I can understand why you would ask it.
I have performed psychological sacrifices,
you know,
I suppose when I decided to give up something that I needed to give up so that I
could move forward into the future.
Right.
That certainly happened when I quit smoking and when I more or less quit
drinking,
I still have a drink from time to time now,
but I quit for 20 years and that was a sacrifice.
I couldn't continue to drink again.
I said I was from northern Alberta.
It was pretty hard drinking culture and I really liked alcohol,
but I couldn't drink and write and do my phd and manage my family
responsibilities.
It was too much.
And so I stopped and that was a good thing.
So that was a sacrifice.